welcome to this video I'm playing uncle
X uncle X from the Netherlands to 169
done let's see Queens gambit the Queens
gambit yeah recently on icc John Watson
started a series presenting the cheek or
on defense it's not an opening that I
particularly trust for black but then
it's always interesting to see a really
good theoretician like what's in making
a case for slightly offbeat opening and
yeah it's quite it's quite interesting
cannot it seems that you cannot really
refute it easily having okay this I
didn't expect Adam that it can be
refuted but don't very present some some
interesting suggestions how to play okay
so wyd quite quickly here um exchanged
on d5 so we have reached them typical
exchange Queens gambit position only
with them a slightly strange light here
unknown 16 normally there are some upon
down to support d5 and the question is
how should i go about that maybe i can i
can just then play a play in a simple
manner exchange down and then in 10 298
26 after the exchange of course honor 3
i'd like to wait if if he wants to a few
castles
I'm a bit worried abroad the open edge
wrong ok so he doesn't doesn't doom
commit yet
nitey five is probably really nonsense
98 that's 95 I cannot play that okay so
let's just protect it I'm not sure maybe
I could have could have from plate with
the temporary one second 00 Alistair
didn't expect but it makes it makes some
sense ok let's get rid of this 95 idea
so this is hanging on age 7 so age 6
maybe it's tricky yep he's going going
for for the long castle I'm I'm going to
try for good counter play ok Quincy tool
I will play a 52 to counter that yeah
but ok i'm still I still have this
covered
I've got a bit of play myself I cannot
he cannot take this for instance might
be three winning the Queen damn now i'm
not sure this isn't this even quite okay
for me so just take and queen a form now
create a form the other screen a three
maybe queen bee father taking of the
night is also not bad wait wait wait the
night is hanging i need you i need to
need to look at this
but isn't this the simple this is scott
i mean queen a three I don't see
something else yeah maybe that's kinky
one but it looks it looks ugly between
83 I can just take and take g-form
nothing to be feared up if you
recaptures on jihad as f2 hanging so
Queen a3 is not really working i King
King be one hour maybe yeah this is this
is just just amend okay so f5 mc5 I mean
to c5 takes rook c8 am this is one
hanging
ok let's prepare that c5 greenie opens
up against the king I still have a I
have an attack on the king I don't care
so much about let's say the Jeep on also
you can try to get it with root g one
but c5 is substantially here he cannot
move king d 2 because of rugby too and
he cannot move them the bishop I mean c5
is really a strong threat it's not them
harmless at all
even immediately c5 was interesting
taking a look-see eight Bishop g5 check
King evade and what is he doing after
that okay but this is such thing
completely sufficient fc5 is so it's um
is a big news yeah yeah well I can place
your form should I place it for ya
okay he's attacking that one
this night should it should I relocated
or should I just a one-night be 3 as a
silly right you don't want to exchange
that very stupid looking very stupid
looking piece on on on a 2 yeah this one
yeah but ok was my idea anyway to get
the night over to d6
ticking III
20 40 seconds where did I spend all that
time
yeah unfortunately what this isn't so
clear even
check
again this was helpful they just blended
default not quite sure what the position
was like without animals
Roxy to is the big idea check
yeah i'm promoting no you take see with
check and then the business upon
promotes
yeah it's resign I really I really let
him back into the game around here
blackest black is an excellent shape of
course yeah maybe I should play Knight B
3 after all yeah maybe it is this better
I don't know yeah this was probably a
bad idea here in this position well the
computer still loves my position but I
felt like I somehow didn't play it
played in the best way it still gives me
a very very big edge here in black
somehow yeah it looks nice i've got this
protected passer but he's got it blocked
III is a weakness but he may be can
sometimes cover it with king d to its
maybe just normal move and I'm not so
sure how to how to proceed i can i can
use the h porn but somehow I expected
more from this no no you have an
interesting game around here it looked
like I'm in a bad shape but I have this
very quickly before b3 and this son is
obviously quite okay for black down here
I'd like to check this briefly because
it did also even that is nervous and
chatting yeah c5 was also really an
option hmm yeah the Chi Goran is
interesting opening it's not
it's not completely stupid to play like
this it's um it's slightly slightly
shaky but it's too interesting play
alright thanks for watching